huh
huh
huh
uh
this is barbara the deaconess of the
church she is here to retrieve the holy
liar to hamill
may the animal arkhan protect you
i'm not really in a position to speak
compared to our acting grand master
but i still want to thank you all on
behalf of all of monstat for your
assistance
fortunately everything was resolved
peacefully
i can't imagine how an all-out war
between the military and the dragon
would have ended
now the fatoui have no choice but to
keep their mouths shut
they must be annoyed that things didn't
turn out as planned for them
this time they even lost their best
excuse to pressure the knights of
fevonius
diplomatically speaking they gained
nothing and on the contrary simply
proved just how vexatious they can be
sounds like quite the story
so
did you bring the holy liar with you
we cannot ask you to keep defending the
liar forever
the senate shall has been pressing me
for a while now
we uh
did bring it with us
um
it's just
it's a little
oh don't worry
i'm not here to collect rent
the church has always received special
the holy funding
oh and barbados
even if i atoned for these sins for the
rest of my life
it would still not be enough
oh
give it here
oh god that's holy liar but how
[Music]
no no
i don't know how you managed to fix it
but you'll never touch the liar again
we uh really should get going that trick
i used to repair the holy liar
i mean the magic i used isn't going to
hold forever you know
what
you're doing
hey don't go
uh
at last monstat's rodent ruler in the
flesh
scurrying through the streets looking
for leftovers
monstad calls this a god
resident rodent beats invasive vermin
don't you dare speak back to me
insolent bard
did you steal it from your master's face
i should have held your tongue
this is a gnosis wouldn't be caught dead
wearing this ugly thing in public
beauty is a waste
when the beholder has no taste
well
we have what we came here for
come before our dear favonian friends
arrive leave nothing for them to find
ah
honorary knight you're awake
um
i wouldn't say he's all right exactly
i found you lying unconscious outside
the cathedral and used my elemental
powers to heal you
that bard awakened first but strangely
my healing powers had almost no effect
on him
this is the first time i've encountered
such a patient
but he just said it's completely normal
and then got up and left the cathedral
he left already where'd he go
the symbol of monstat's hero that's what
he said
i wanted to stop him but gene i i mean
master gene
said
remembers venti healing under that tree
before
it's probably due to the connection
between windrise and the animal archon
master gina's figured it out as well but
we can't tell barbara
peace
uh
[Music]
bet you can't keep up with me
the wind amongst the branches is good i
love the way it smells
i said the exact same thing last time
uh
why do i only say these things when i'm
down on my luck
ah so you noticed
ah
this isn't something i meant to discuss
with ordinary people
but i suppose i can let you in on the
secret
as you know
visions are external magical foci that
only a small minority of people possess
they use these visions to channel
elemental power
in truth
every wielder of a vision is one who can
attain godhood and ascend to celestia
we call such people allergens
allergens pyman's never heard of them
before
that's because this is a secret that
only archons are privy to
we don't need primitive tools like
visions
instead each archon has an internal
magical focus that resonates directly
with celestia itself
known as a gnosis
it's just a glowing glass ball i carry
around to avoid suspicion
so who is that nasty woman who sent my
mom flying and stole your gnosis
her name is senora
number eight of the harbingers
she and the rest of the harbingers have
been given god-like executive authority
by the saritza
and with it strength surpassing that of
other mortals
[Music]
isn't that
indeed
she is one of the seven
the tsaritsa who reigns from her winter
palace and the one person that the
fatoui harbingers all answer to
the seven don't always get along well
but still
i never thought that she would plot to
steal another arkhan's gnosis
uh
how should i put this
500 years ago i knew her well
but i can't say the same is true now
you see
a certain catastrophe happened 500 years
ago and after that she cut off all ties
with me
but we can save discussion of the
cryoarchon and the fatoui for another
day
if you seek the rest of the seven
many difficulties lie ahead of you still
you should head for monstat's
neighboring nation of leo
the geo arkhan who reigns there unlike
me administrates his entire region
personally
he only descends once every year to give
his divine predictions which set the
direction for leo for the rest of that
year
even so it sounds like he works much
harder than a certain someone hmm
in any case this year's rite of
dissension is soon to begin
if you miss it you'll just have to wait
another year
what oh why didn't you tell us before
well then bye we're going
one moment to win born outlander
yep
traveler
as you set off on your journey once
again you must remember that the journey
itself has meaning
the birds of tavat the songs in the
cities the tsuritsa her fatoui and the
monsters
they are all part of your journey
the destination is not everything
so before you reach the end keep your
eyes open
use the chance to take in the world
around you
great
so that's that for the animal archons
admonishments back to venti time
if you want to chat now's the time a
bard stays not always in a single climb
well then best be off to leeway if the
dissension ritual you failed to tally
then another year you must dally
so
[Music]
you